[Musik]
so heute locken wir mal ein bisschen wir
sind auf der liste
das ist das erste mal dass sie hier in
dortmund stattfindet erhalten und so gut
wie gar nicht aber wir haben auf jeden
fall vereinigung bevor ich festgehalten
so unschön guten morgen liebe
messebesucher manchmal ich sehe seid ihr
für den 11 programmpunkte es geht um
kies kit ist immer dass einfach jeder
banken kann und ich habe angefangen
wirklich zb von nehmen und dann habe ich
schon mitbekommen dass sein partner ganz
habe ich das dabei ist weil der steht ja
nun mal hinterher kam richtig kann mir
oftmals viel hallo sagen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
danke
es war
[Musik]
die medien
sie wollen auch eine hälfte ist und eine
verteilen
ich hoffe meine ist genauso
eine bloße die mädels hier
[Applaus]
[Musik]
verbessere zuvor versucht
rückläufig
[Musik]
es ist ein grießpudding mit kokos wenn
man es ganz strengen kriens pudding mit
kokos ist ein bisschen butter mit drin
ist habe ich da ja sind nicht mit drin
genau mutter ist mit drillisch dri
scopus bis ihr mann vor dem haus
abkühlen lassen und jetzt ist es form
waren das ist ganz cool
jetzt können wir das zu kugeln formen
sind auch gleich getoppt
vielleicht wisst ihr schon mit da ich
[Gelächter]
könnte mir sogar helfen
hast du lust hast
mainz hat eine lust ja echt cool dass
meine rettung heute
sie haben
kannst du mal wieder heiß
alena
[Musik]
man muss sich drauf
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
und was sagt ihr
ja ich befürchte er nicht nennen
in sechs folgen die sie zu hause sagt
der 14-jährige ständen war und dann sagt
die junge praktikantin dann kannst du
mich mal dass das spielen weil ich ja
auch keine zeit dann gibt es ihn als
erstes jetzt als bisher
das erst mal verteilt vielen dank für
ihre hilfe und applaus
[Applaus]
natürlich
verteilt
[Musik]
so bin ich auch wieder der vorhin
gestartet doch nicht alle leute haben
von der wand und einfach dabei ja aber
einige glauben da kann ich doch nicht
erkennen kann ja gar nicht ob das war
total kurzweilig spannend erinnert sich
ja gesagt das war ein erstes
öffentliches ja ich bin auch sehr
glücklich
ich habe wie gesagt von catan jetzt
erfahren dass ich hier sein darf und ich
bin so froh darüber dass ich mal gesagt
ich glaube was gerade toll
deutlich ist die faszination ist das was
die macht sehr einfache dinge sind und
wir auch gemerkt haben
die zeit zu bringen das macht total spaß
bereiten
zu stricken und es ist tatsächlich auch
sofort machbar und es ist ja auch was
was ist mit euch nicht durch die
präsentationen
[Gelächter]
jeden tag
oder ist das für dich auch jungs tun
ich würde das so gerne mag ja aber ich
möchte auch so ein richtiger traum von
mir und das möchten wir auch reagieren
wenn ich jetzt dann fängt ja was heißt
schon best of kitty switching und gibt
ja ich habe mir ein anderes konzept
überlegt aber nicht zu viel verraten ja
das würde ich jetzt auch so dankeschön
das freut nicht dankeschön an denen doch
es soll in den weg von der ist doch toll
also mehr hat wäre auch volkmann das ist
tatsächlich was ja stehen nochmals nur
visuell sieht sondern das probieren und
dann holt auch das hier da war
[Applaus]
[Musik]
es gibt noch ein interview
mit dem blabla kaffee
mega gespannt und der handel noch mit
dabei
[Musik]
ja
dass die interviewerin achten
[Musik]
das wenig
ich wähle mit
die harmonie
[Musik]
meinung
ich weiß nicht ob nicht reden sein soll
dem entscheidend absetzen wollte oder
weil ihr da seid weil ich jetzt gleich
etwas packen werde aber ich hoffe
natürlich dass letzterer die ständig
erstmal vorrichtung bisschen nervös ich
habe diese woche für mich stand noch nie
auf einer bühne und das war gestern das
erste mal sehen wird es zweimal ja ich
bin die kicker von kirchen
ein
die früchte
ein tennisarm weil das gekühlt ist sich
doch einmal dass sich das verbindet
vor allem einigen können
andere bieten
ja
fast wie buffalo genau und dann einfach
mit dem finger aber das weißt du einfach
so ein sondern antworten und natürlich
die in diese kaninchen dann kann man
gleich nochmal wissen mussten 16 spielen
[Musik]
also alles ok
und irgendwann
[Musik]
gerne denke auf die bühne
ich hab die hallen und vor allem schöner
name klinik wenn sie das mit was man
noch mehr tun für den läufer genau
die habe ich schon ganz klein bisschen
gesagt die gestaltung mit
[Musik]
so gut damit den anfang
ja
[Musik]
super
also den zwei tagen nach hause machen
natürlich den zwischenstopp es irgendwo
was wir heute nicht kennen dass wir zum
kochen
ich habe es richtig genossen ganz
richtig spaß gemacht und ich habe sie
auch noch gar nicht gesehen und ich bin
ich später mal an und bin auch gespannt
wie das dann so von außerhalb haben also
sehr freut sich dass die 300 bis zum
ende und dann schaltete er im nächsten
schritt sind wieder eindrucksvoll links
[Musik]